*clap 1*
*clap 2*
Fashion Review
that's right
that's what this channel needs right now
a top ten list
FINALLY
*giggles*
A top ten list
of something I know barely anything about
that'll do it
that'll get them watching
So, I wanted to make another video on fashion
but specifically "fashion memes"
and I had a few things in mind already
but I still asked you guys on twitter
for some suggestions and...
OH BOI
There was a lot of fashion memes out there...
Hey, you wanna look like a...
Dragon Pear?
What in the world...
I think it's safe to say that fashion and memes are becoming...
*clap 1*
*clap 2*
closer and closer
You have these
steal his looks memes
remember those?
Heh...
very cheap price
very good price (yes)
but let's go through my
'Top 10 fashion memes' lists everybody.
yea, for some reason I thought it was a good idea to do a 'Top 10' of this.
NUMBER 1
*clap 1*
*clap 2*
Balenciaga IKEA bag
that's right everybody
from a high end designer,
Balenciaga
they call it the arena extra large shopping tote
it's going viral because do you notice that it looks something similar to...
maybe the IKEA bag
hahahahaheheheheh...
shopping bag known as the 'FRAKTA' ?
yes, the 'FRAKTA' everyone.
frakta
oh
"FRAKTA"
it's "Frakta".
stop stealing our culture!
how many meatballs can I fit into that
BAD BOI
HMM?
You can get the Balenciaga designer bag for $2,145
ooh,
wow,
ooh
or the low low price of 99 cents per IKEA's
frakta
and best of all
no assembly required on that particular IKEA item
for once!
you don't see that little wrench...you know?
OH
MY GOD
i mean i... i'd buy it
just to represent SWEDEN
i also really like the
IKEA Yeezys'
so yeah
for the low price of 2,140
DOLLARS
you too can embrace
Swedish culture
i mean i practically grew up with these bags
it's kinda funny
HEH
IKEA responds to Balenciaga's blue bag
IN THE
BEST
WAY
POSSIBLE
so they responded with the meme
it wasn't really much of a meme
it really was
kind of disappointing...
*clap 1*
*clap 2*
NUMBER 2
unintentional vegana
do you wanna dress up looking like a vegana?
oh, i'm sorry
let me rephrase that
do you wanna dress up looking like a VEGANA?
just for a thousand dollars
*hmmmm?*
that's right
i know which option you're picking
well, look no further
this
Fendi scarf
looks like
HMMM?!
Hmm...Hmm...Heh..Heh.Heh...
HHHMMMMMM??
hm...
hm...HM...
You know
i feel bad, if anyone's seen a vegana like that
I'm sorry...
Here's the upside down version...
Maybe this
item in particular
should have been
on a model
and not just shown itself
just-
just a thought.
food for thought..
or just thought...
*clap 1*
*clap 2*
NUMBER 3 on our list everybody
That's right
We're going fast
We're going HARD
Here's a meme that I personally fell for
That's right
I bought this belt
I really like this brand. It's the 'ALYX' roller coaster belt
You've probably seen these.
They're quite popular
They go for £273
They're really cool belts
OKAY?
STOP HATING!
DON'T JUDGE ME!
OKAY?!
They're cool belts
I like the blr-...brand
what do you want from me?
You can buy these
rip-off ones for
30 bucks
I've seen even less
Obviously...
you shouldn't...
You shouldn't do that
Okay?
Don't-
Don't steal
The reason why I'm bringing up the-
the copy is because the original
The £273 one
It doesn't fit
It doesn't fit any pants
You can't wear this belt
So you pay...
Heh
You pay over $300 for a belt that you can't use
Good job
I have to help out the people
that are
curious on to how to actually put this damn belt to use (YES! Help me)
and all our people
are spending money (How the hell do I put it on?)
on this
and
can't even use out of it which is unfortunate
but I'm here to help
So, what are the tips?
This is not fitting in here
That makes no sense
like you just cannot do it
Practically
if you wanna wear this belt
you gotta go to a tailor
to enter the belt
so if you wanna spend like I dont know an hour?
Putting the belt on
You can
you can get it through
but if you have...I don't know...
different fabric material?
You're likely to just break your pants
I don't know
Sad
Just SAD
*clap*
NUMBER 4
GUCCI Gundam
~GUCCI gang
GUCCI gun
Gush- GUCCI gung
GUCCI Gundam~
Do you wanna dress like your favorite anime character
for the low price of  $1,700
cause GUCCI
sold these
jackets or outfits
for, eh,
for that price
and
on the Japanese market
people were quick to point out
that they look very similar
to the
Gundam outfits
Heh...
I mean look at the cuts,
Look at the belt,
Look at the neck...
The shoulders,
The boots
It's pretty similar.
They even have the
The-
The red version of the jacke-
It's a pretty jacket I'm not gonna lie
I like-
I would wear it
which it was also resembles to another gundam character
Gucci made a statement about this, apparently
where they said that
uh
it wasn't intentional
or maybe they watched Gundam and that's how it sorta happened
but they can either deny or confirm
but
considering how Gucci already does a lot of anime or vintage-anime inspired looks
i think it's safe to say that this was an inspiration, at least.
could this be the world's most expensive cosplay?
¯\_(ツ)_/¯
NUMBER FIVE, everybody.
Montclair! they've been doing a lot of
collaborations, I think they call it
'Montclair genius', honestly I think a lot
of them are really dope. They did one with
Craig-- Craig Green? and it's pretty crazy,
I saw a lot of you guys sending me this
one and I- I've seen it already, I wanted
to bring it up in my last video. This is
just-- the thing that I think a lot of
people don't realize, these are just
promotional designs you may think "oh, who-- how
would anyone possibly wear this this is
just ridiculous!" they're not made to wear
they're just made to, I don't know be
promo get people to talk about it and
clearly it works but even then I can
appreciate the design of it, I think it
looks awesome. And then looking at the
actual commercial jacket of it it's cool--
it's a cool jacket, like I would buy it
unless- I, if I needed a new jacket which
I don't,
so I'm not gonna spend money on it. It's a cool
jacket, I gotta give him props-- that's
not why I'm bringing up Montclair! the
reason why is cause they did a
collaboration with Pier Paolo Pich- Piccioli? And, uh, it's something
uh, it's, eh, it's something to say the least
I don't know, eheh, it looks like those dolls
what are they called? Again, they're
interesting to look at. I can at least
appreciate the design. But I think what
blows my mind on this is that these are
actually the commercial pieces that you
can buy for £2,415.
And guess what?
they're all sold out, so even if you wanted to, for some reason, buy it, you can't.
They're sold out. All of them. I want to see people
wear these. They're probably really warm
and comfortable to be fair, heh. Can you
imagine going out in a snowstorm? "Don't
worry fam I got just the outfit." Very
nice. Number six goes to video games!
That's right. I kind of combine this
category, uh, you've probably seen this it
was a few years ago where the final
fantasy character, Lightning, did a
collaboration with Louboutin, ah,  to
promote these handbags and outfits, uh,
way to hit a very niche market of, uh,
female gamers that are also loaded, and
also into high-end fashion, *snickers*
funny enough I think today-- or maybe a
few days ago-- Capcom did a similar thing,
although they're not collaborating with
any fashion brand, they did launch their
own cr- clothing pieces, ah, as a connection to
their launch of their new game 'Devil May
Cry 5'. Uh, so, the three main characters, they
have a 'super luxury replica custom
version'. 'Super luxury' to say the least. Uh,
You can do, eh-- you can first of all get this, uh,
jacket, that's missing half the arm, for
¥7,500-- eh, ¥750,000 yen, which I
think is about... $6,650. What's funny about this is
that you can buy it with the video game. *chuckles*
'Yes, please, gimme the jacket and the
video game, so I can wear it while
playing!' I mean, they're pretty pieces, I
think if you put these in a high-end
fashion store, no one would really
question about it. Combining it w-with this, ah,
video game it's kind of silly, but... I
don't know there's something interesting
about it as well. So this jacket is, uh, the
scanned version of Da-Dante's jacket. It's a cool jacket. Another very,
very expensive cosplay. To be fair, it
looks like extremely high quality at
least from what I can tell from it. You
know people will be buying. You know
people will be dropping... money on this,
big time. I mean this Final Fantasy or
Japanese type of games are always made
to m-make the characters look 'cool' in the
strangest way possible, so I kind of get
it. It makes sense, I just wonder who will
fall for this meme. Number seven! I just
spit everywhere...
Gucci! That's right! They get their own
category! Congratulations! You know, I
wanted to just bring up their face masks.
I wish I talked about in the last video.
I was so confused. Why would people wear
these face masks? I mean I bought one
myself so I guess I shouldn't be asking
that. They're silly to say the least, but
they're not crazy expensive. £175. Please don't quote
me on that, heh.
I'm just saying, compared to all these
other items, they're not that crazy. Uh, but
the real reason Gucci gets on this meme
the fact that they have this, sort of,
Russian-babushka inspired outfits.
Like this one for example-- it's literally
the... 'get the look' on this one 'shop the
look'
Okay, sure 'that'll be 6,000.' Okay! Sure! sure,
why not? This was literally a meme on my
own subreddit. Gucci: 5,000. Babushka: half a
dollar, hahaha.
Look at that. What is that?
No!
No! I don't know, the thing with Gucci
is like... they have all these really
silly items, but, like I mentioned in the
last video they do have really cool
pieces as well, that I genuinely, uh, do like.
And ever since their latest designer
took in they- they honestly, they've been
killing it, so they get a high spot on
the list! Number eight! Moving on. Big
shoes everybody! And they're the meme
that I fell for. I mean, who would
possibly buy big shoes? why would anyone
fall for this meme? Heheh, you have the Balenciaga shoes that got super popular... You have the Gucci shoes that are really big and
uh, same sense. I mean they're so similar.
It's almost like, uh, one type of shoe gets
popular and then all the other brands
just try and see who can yell the
loudest. It's interesting to look back at
people's opinion on these type of shoes,
a year ago. I know some people still
feel this way but... "They make the worst
shoe ever made, that they still will
probably buy." "$800?" "Haha, you're tellin' me 800 lies." "Woah!"
But now you see so many brands just kinda,
taking and borrowing from this design as
well.
Uh... I think that's interesting. You know,
people, first they laugh, and then they
they copy it. Then you, of course, have
that one-- that one person that just has
to take it about 5,00 steps too
far.
Thank you, Vêtements. But, of course, let's
not ignore the godfather of sneakers.
The king of sneakers. The Maison
Margiela Fusion Sneaker. Oh yeah.
Just £1,400. You
know most people, when they buy expensive
sneakers, they want to make sure that, eh,
nothing gets on them. You know, no
dirt whatsoever. Ah, with these you really
don't have to worry. I think the more
dirt, the better!
I love reading the reviews on these as
well. "Is this a joke? This is a new low.
Super tacky. Fashion isn't fashion if it
makes you look bad. Pass!" I mean, people
clearly are buying them. From most places
I saw, they were sold out.
Number nine! we're getting there,
everybody.Number nine goes to Vetements,
and what can I say about Vetements?
Well, uh, they l-- obviously, they like it
big. And oversized. The thing though, I'm a
bit conflicted about them, because I un-- I
uniroinically like it. Despite it
looking very silly, over the top, and I
think a lot of people would probably ask
'why the hell would you spend money on that?'
I read the-- I read this quote
about Vetements, that said, "I think the
hype around Vetements says more about how
boring fashion is right now, than it does
about Vetements itself." and I want to say
I kinda have to agree they do cool
pieces in a way that is at least unique
maybe it maybe I'm wrong here I don't
know it's the same look at guys fashion
for example it's t-shirts hoodies and
sweatshirts and it doesn't really get
any weirder than that it doesn't get it
really doesn't go outside of that box at
least for most people
I mean street wear is and basically as
far as it goes for most most guys around
my age or younger so I like what they're
doing I think it's interesting I also
thought it was interesting with the
latest collection the the designer comes
from Georgia and he left QR codes
incorporated in his in his pieces so
that people can found out the story
about Georgia
he said that growing up in Georgia
everyone wore the exact same clothes
they're mixing fashion with spreading a
message so despite it being you know in
a lot of people's eyes very silly and
over-the-top it just have some more
depth to it as well and I don't know
that's cool number 10 spot we finally
did it
who's gonna take it obviously obviously
Balenciaga I mean I've already mentioned
them so many times in this video it's
almost like they need a video on its own
they definitely deserve the number one
spot from the Ikea bag to the Macdonald
Fry's shoes
half price 425 pounds very nice to the
Balenciaga Crocs super high heels to the
Balenciaga supermarket
should we bang through the Balenciaga
shirt t-shirt shirt yes of course - the
Balenciaga multi-layered jacket multi
multi Multi multi layer jackets only
9000 valency agha is clearly leading
this meme there's fashion meme of not
taking itself too seriously at all I
guess I don't know but the same thing
with vetements I think it's interesting
they're doing more you know despite
being very silly everyone makes fun of
Balenciaga it's like it's a thing they
did a collaboration with World Food
Program where they donated $250,000 to
end world hunger in 2030 and they give
away part of the profits from the sales
to this cause you can criticize it for
being overly expensive and all these
things but at least they're doing
something positive my sweet daughter
have nothing love proud
pffff!!! hahaha
*inhales*
well here is the newest item from
high-end clothing brand Balenciaga one
of the items in their fall 2018 line is
a t-shirt shirt it looks a lot like a
t-shirt attached to a collared shirt and
if you think that's weird wait until you
hear the price the newest fashion trend
will cost you 1245 bucks oh I think it's
easy to criticize how ridiculously
over-the-top and overly expensive these
items are and how you can spend that
money on literally anything else and you
know I've done that myself it's it's
it's a funny it's a it's a gag that
everyone plays into but the thing is
these brands know what they're doing I
mean they know that the more people talk
about them the better so while a lot of
people show these things to ridicule it
it obviously helps build the brands as
well and they are aware of it it's the
same of that Kanye video you know they
they wear these stupid outfits and
everyone's like haha look how dumb they
look it's not like they don't know what
they were wearing it felt like they just
accidentally fell into this outfit me
like oh no this is so embarrassing
people talked about the video because of
the outfits and it's this exact same
thing with this song have been popular
otherwise I think probably not as much
at the very least people always seem to
so upset about the prices as well why
are these so expensive why would anyone
pay for this I will seem like really
angry comments about it but it's almost
like the prize sort of legitimizes it if
these clothes didn't cost much then
people wouldn't care and if they closed
it and cost that much then people
wouldn't buy it people wouldn't want it
if these items were cheap then it
wouldn't have that desirable effect for
people while we so while a lot of people
share these items
as a way to ridicule and make fun of
that's what makes it possible for them
to exist it's almost like while making
fun of them we are making fun of
ourselves that sounded very deep so on
that note I'm gonna end that video there
what do you guys think let me know do
you agree with this list is there
something I missed I pretty sure there's
a lot this was interesting regardless
leave a like if you enjoyed and I will
see you guys tomorrow bye (bye hope you enjoyed!)